foreign
violence on the streets of Paris
protesters against police
of tear gas an attempt to push back a
furious crowd
[Music]
angry after a gunman opened fire at a
Kurdish Cultural Center at lunchtime
shooting at least six people
the scene shortly before tensions boiled
over the interior Minister said
investigators would confirm if Kurds
were specifically targeted
it's not clear that this person was
politically active and involved even if
what he did was a characterized attack
against foreigners but it'll be for the
Judiciary investigation to confirm that
the shootings happened in a busy
Multicultural Street in the central 10th
District a 69 year old French man has
been arrested
I can tell you there are three people
dead there are two people in a critical
condition and two people with minor
injuries the perpetrator who has been
arrested was also wounded in the face
officials say he was already known to
police with reports he was linked to a
saber attack on migrants in 2021.
authorities are investigating whether
racism fueled today's killings
to date we do not really know the
motivations of this killer the
investigation is ongoing the
neighborhood is completely cordoned off
I ask all residents and inhabitants not
to go to the neighborhood to those who
are at home to stay there for the moment
the neighborhood will likely be cordoned
off all day
France is still on alert after a string
of deadly attacks by Islamic extremists
in 2015 and 2016.
authorities say there's currently no
indication of a terrorist motive today
and that the gunman acted alone
the president has sent his condolences
to France's Kurds condemning the heinous
killings
[Music]
but the attack has struck at the heart
of this community
people here are demanding answers and
Justice Siobhan Robbins Sky News